und jetzt das heute journal live aus
Ankara mit Christian Sievers
guten Abend in allen live aus der
Hauptstadt der Türkei nach der Wahl ist
vor der Wahl die Anspannung hier bleibt
auf beiden Seiten Präsident recept type
Erdogan und sein Herausforderer Kemal
Kilic stardolo müssen antreten noch mal
Stichwahl in zwei Wochen weil keiner von
beiden über 50% kam heute ist das Leben
zurück in Ankara nachdem gestern am
Wahlabend eine gespenstische Stille über
den sonst so quirligen Städten dieses
Landes lag
aber in allen Gesprächen geht es heute
darum was jetzt kommt nach einer wirren
Wahlnacht zeigt sich eins die Tiefe
Spaltung dieses Landes Lena Sünder Bruch
war heute in Ankara unterwegs
die Feiern vor der Parteizentrale von
Erdogans AKP sind abgeklungen doch die
Freude bei seinen Anhängern über die
Ereignisse der Wahlnacht hält an diese
Deutsch Türken sind AKP Mitglieder und
extra aus Stuttgart angereist um die
Atmosphäre live mitzuerleben
wir haben wieder gewonnen es hat mich
sehr erfreut wir haben nicht 50 Prozent
geschafft also 50 plus 1 haben wir nicht
geschafft aber jetzt in der zweiten Tour
denke ich dass ich noch glücklicher sein
werde diese Generation kennt niemand
anderen als Erdogan oder die konservativ
islamische AKP an der Spitze der Türkei
viele sind trotz aller Kritik überzeugt
von ihr und ihrem Vorsitzenden
weil ich der Meinung bin dass er sich
sehr sehr gut für die ich sag mal
deutsch Türken einsetzt oder allgemein
für die Türken im Ausland einsetzt die
Türkei versucht an den letzten Jahren
wirklich außer politisch da zu sein oder
auch in der Rüstungsindustrie dieser
Entwicklung sind uns wichtig und da
erhoffen wir uns einfach dass mit Herr
Erdogan quasi die nächsten fünf Jahre
das noch mal weitergeht doch es gibt
auch die die denken dass sich das Land
mit einer weiteren Amtszeit Erdogans
noch mehr in eine gefährliche Richtung
entwickeln würde wie der Besitzer dieses
Cafés der sich nicht vor der Kamera
zeigen möchte er sagt uns nur er will
die Türkei verlassen denn Erdogan an der
Macht bleibt auch seine Stammkundin hat
Angst davor
es wird sich sehr stark auf die Frauen
auswirken die Wahlkampagne basierte auf
Diskriminierung und Unterdrückung von
Frauen darüber machen wir uns große
Sorgen
ihr Freund Adam will die Hoffnung noch
nicht ganz aufgeben
Opposition im Parlament hat die
Opposition dazugewonnen das ist ein
kleiner Sieg für uns daran werden wir
uns festhalten und auf ein besseres
Ergebnis in der Stichwahl hoffen dass
Liebe fürchtet dass Erdogan die Justiz
weiter politisiert die Institutionen
noch mehr aushöhlt dass sich die
Währungskrise verschlimmert
combine all das zusammen wir zu einer
Abwanderung von Frauen in andere Länder
führen
das wird ein Faktor sein ein großer
Faktor
die einen verlassen das Land weil sie
Repressalien fürchten die anderen kehren
nach Deutschland zurück und fühlen sich
als Sieger
wer wie wir in Deutschland diesen
geregelten Ablauf von Prognose
Hochrechnungen und dem vorläufigen
amtlichen Endergebnis gewohnt ist dem
musste diese Wahlnacht hier vorkommen
wie ein Schock da beschuldigt die
Opposition die Regierung die Auszählung
zu sabotieren da veröffentlicht die
staatliche Nachrichtenagentur
Zwischenergebnisse die den Präsidenten
weit vorne sehen obwohl klar ist die
Hochburgen des Kontrahenten sind darin
noch gar nicht enthalten verglichen mit
den Erwartungen im Vorfeld ist das
Ergebnis für die Opposition eine
Enttäuschung auch wenn Sie Erdogan zum
ersten Mal überhaupt in eine zweite
Runde gezogen hat die politische
Situation beschreibt jetzt Anna Feist
wir kämpfen bis zum bitteren Ende
twittert Erdogans Kontrahent dann sein
Schlachthof
ich bin hier ich bin hier ihr seid auch
hier ich werde bis zum Ende kämpfen ich
bin hier
gibt sich kampfeslustig wohl wissend
dass die nächsten zwei Wochen die
härtesten seiner politischen Karriere
werden könnten Rückblick noch in der
Nacht schrumpfen die Prognosen für
Erdogan von fast 60 auf 49 Prozent sein
Herausforderer pendelt sich bei 45% ein
Erdogan interpretiert das so
die Tatsache dass die Wahlergebnisse
noch nicht endgültig fest stehen ändert
nichts daran dass die Wahl unserer
Nation eindeutig zu unseren Gunsten
ausgefallen ist
an diesem Nachmittag dann steht fest es
wird eine Stichwahl geben und mit ihr
kommt ein dritter ins Spiel Sinan oan
der dritte Präsidentschaftskandidat
Vorsitzender eines
ultra-nationalistischen Bündnis mit gut
fünf Prozent der Stimmen hinter sich MZF
Interview gefällt er sich in der neuen
Rolle in den Stichwahlen könnten wir die
entscheidenden Stimmen liefern
vielleicht sind wir sogar der
Königsmacher deshalb sind wir mit dem
Ergebnis zufrieden
nur eine Bedingung habe er an die die
seine stimmen wollen keine gemeinsame
Sache mit der prokurdischen HDP ich will
dass der Abstand zu Terroristen gewahrt
wird die HDP kriegt das nicht hin eine
Zwickmühle denn auch die Stimmen der
Kurden wird er brauchen wenn er in zwei
Wochen erneut im Rennen zum Präsidenten
antritt und noch etwas dürfte am Erdogan
Herausforderer zerren die Journalistin
Nagel haben alte sieht den Zusammenhalt
des Sechser Bündnis um Kilo Stau wo du
in Gefahr ihre Prognose für den
Kandidaten daher düster
man kann sagen von heute aus dass
Erdogan sehr wahrscheinlich in der
zweiten Runde gewinnen wird
[Musik]
auch türkische Liebeslieder und ein
großes Bier können da nicht so recht
trösten
[Musik]
ich hatte eh keine Erwartung und nun
geht diese Hoffnungslosigkeit wieder
weiter ich bin daran so gewöhnt die da
oben haben uns die Hoffnungslosigkeit
gelehrt das ist das Einzige was mich
jetzt noch betrübt
er werde Grillitsch da wo du trotzdem
wieder seine Stimme geben aber so sagte
er diesmal ohne Hoffnung
vielen Dank sind heute die
triumphierenden Blicke der Erdogan
Anhänger zu erleben und Stille
Verzweiflung bei denen die ihr Land
jetzt in dunkle Zeiten ableiten sehen
die uns hier sagen wir sitzen auf
gepackten Koffern bereit unsere Heimat
zu verlassen
Jörg brasis ist unser ZDF Türkei
Korrespondent Jörg guten Abend jetzt
also Stichwahl heißt das der ganze
Wahlkampf geht quasi wieder von neuem
los also davon müssen wir ausgehen in
der Tat weil jetzt sind noch zwei Wochen
Zeit um letztlich dafür zu sorgen dass
die Wähler die gestern gewählt haben
mindestens diese Welle wieder
mobilisiert werden dass sie wieder zu
den Ohren gehen ähm und ich rechne schon
damit dass wir jetzt in den nächsten
zwei Wochen einen Wahlkampf erleben
werden der sich wieder sehr zu spitzt in
der auch Präsident Erdogan
wieder angreifen wird und wieder
versuchen wird in die Ecke zu stellen in
der sie ihn haben will um eben seine
Wähler zu motivieren um dazu ohne zu
gehen das ist nämlich etwas was wir
jetzt in der Tat gesehen haben dass er
durch die Medien Macht die er besitzt
und dir auch eingesetzt hat ganz gezielt
eben Kilic Stolo in dieser Ecke stellen
konnte dass er eben mit Terroristen
paktiert und
Ängste geschürter die die Leute dann
dazu gebracht haben dann doch zur ohne
zu gehen und bei Ihnen das Kreuz zu
machen und das wird er jetzt in den
nächsten zwei Wochen auf jeden Fall tun
jetzt natürlich die Gretchenfrage Jörg
wer ist im Vorteil am Ende wer wird die
Stichwahl gewinnen da kommt es offenbar
ja auf jemanden an den wir gerade kurz
gesehen haben im Film der in der ersten
Runde persönlich für seine eigenen
Ambition chancenlos war das ist richtig
ich habe heute mit ihm gesprochen mein
Gefühl sagt also dass er politisch dem
Erdogan Lager wahrscheinlich mehr steht
auf der anderen Seite vielleicht noch
mal sagen das sind stimmen dann
möglicherweise auf einen der beiden
verteilt werden genau Sinan Ohren der
jetzt in der Stichwahl nicht mehr
antreten darf hat etwas über 5% der
Stimmen bekommen man kann jetzt glaube
ich nicht sagen dass ich diese Stimmen
dem einen oder anderen Lager dann
letztlich zuordnen auch seine
Gefolgschaft ist durchaus
gespalten man muss jetzt mal schauen
auch welche Gespräche mit ihm geführt
werden ich kann mir vorstellen dass
beide Seiten jetzt mit ihm großen
Gesprächsbedarf haben um ihm auch was
anzubieten und da muss man sehen er
hatte uns gesagt dass er am Freitag eine
Empfehlung aussprechen will Ende der
Woche er sagt die Türkei hat nicht mehr
viel Zeit er will dann eine Wahl
Empfehlung geben für seine für seine
Unterstützer wenn sie dann werden sollen
in zwei Wochen sind gespannt herzlichen
Dank für diese Analyse heute Abend
wieder bei uns
ja die Helden dieses Landes das sind
zehntausende Wahlhelferinnen und
Wahlhelfer
hunderttausende
wahlbeobachtende Bürger die jede
einzelne Wahlurne nicht aus den Augen
lassen wollten die bis zur Erschöpfung
und darüber hinaus aufpassen wollten
dass sie nicht betrogen wurden diese
Bilder machen hier in der Türkei heute
auf Social Media die Runde schon die
Ausgangsbedingungen waren ja krass
unterschiedlich Beispiel die
Abschlusskundgebung von Präsident
Erdogan haben 31 Sender live übertragen
die seines Kontrahenten lief bei einem
Michael Link ist FDP
Bundestagsabgeordneter und Chef der
internationalen Wahl Beobachter Mission
hier in der Türkei und jetzt live bei
uns Herr Link schönen guten Abend schön
dass Sie bei uns sind guten Abend sie
waren heute quasi in allen türkischen
Wohnzimmern zur Gast eine
Pressekonferenz gegeben bei der sie
quasi ein Urteil aus internationaler
Sicht über diese Wahl gefällt haben wie
sah das aus oder wie sieht das aus also
Richter sind wir nicht aber wir sind
Beobachter genau und ich sage immer
unser schärfste Waffe unser eigenzige
Waffe ist das Wort wir schauen hin und
wir berichten was wir beobachten und was
wir gesehen haben war in der Tat ein
Wahlkampf in dem es keine
Chancengleichheit gab die Beobachtung
hat keine Fälschung jetzt bei der
Auszählung ergeben aber sehr wohl war
keine Chancengleichheit im Wahlkampf da
zum Beispiel eben dadurch dass viele
Journalisten inhaftiert waren vor allem
aber eben auch dass der Amtsinhaber
Präsident Erdogan im Fernsehen im
öffentlichen Fernsehen und das ist hier
der stärkste Dauergast war während
Killisch darunter so gut wie nie zu
sehen war und wenn dann negativ Erdogan
im staatlichen Fernsehen jetzt die Frage
an Sie natürlich vor der Stichwahl wie
kann man sicherstellen dass die korrekt
läuft
wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr wenn Sie
das was Sie gerade beschreiben aber wenn
ihr nicht abstellen können Instrumente
Instrumente wie wir eingreifen könnten
haben wir nicht aber unsere Bericht und
die Stärke unseres Berichts ist eben
dass wir auf die Probleme Hinweise und
die spielte diese Berichte spielen schon
eine Rolle weil für viele Türkinnen und
Türken der Wahlprozess der demokratische
Wahlprozess wichtig ist und wenn Sie das
Gefühl haben das betrogen wird wenn Sie
das Gefühl haben dass vielleicht nicht
falsch ausgezählt aber das ist eben
keine Chancengleichheit gibt dann kann
es durchaus auch noch mal dazu führen
dass viele sich noch mal anders
entscheiden weil es gibt hier in der
Türkei ein tiefes Tiefe wurzeltes
demokratisches Gefühl es gibt ein Gefühl
diese Demokratie auch wirklich
tatsächlich auch zu leben und das ist
etwas was die Türkei in demokratische
Hinsicht durchaus auch von anderen
Staaten wie zum Beispiel Russland oder
Belarus wo wir ja wirklich gefälschte
Wahlen haben deutlich unterscheidet was
ist bei ihnen gibt der Link ist eine
Passion quasi für Wahlbeobachtung sie
machen das hier nicht zum ersten Mal sie
waren zum Beispiel in den USA als Donald
Trump die verlorene die durch ihn
verlorene Wahl nicht anerkennen wollte
ist das jetzt wenn Sie das mal so ein
bisschen von der weiteren Perspektive
sehen so ein um sich greifendes Phänomen
dass die Wahlen immer nur dann anerkannt
werden wenn sie für einen persönlich
positiv verlaufen sind ja das ist dann
Phänomen was wir zwar nicht neu haben
wir zurzeit eben sehr deutlich haben und
vor allem haben wir Misstrauen in die
wirklich Integrität das Wahlsystems das
ist wahrsystem auch tatsächlich wirklich
funktioniert und deshalb ist so wichtig
das waren Transparenz sind und da ist
die hiesige Wahlkommission diese der
hohe Wahl Rad wieder hier heißt auch
nicht gerade ein Musterbeispiel an
Transparenz eine Frage noch zur
deutschen Sicht auf das ganze die Grünen
hatten ja im Vorfeld aufgerufen und zwar
Abwahl von Erdogan sie waren lange
selbst Staatsminister im Auswärtigen Amt
wie sollte Deutschland denn jetzt
umgehen mit Rezept Erdogan mit dem ja
offenbar noch weiter zu rechnen sein
könnte auf keinen Fall belehrend denn es
geht hier nicht darum dass wir den
Türken sagen was sie zu tun haben
sondern es geht darum dass die Türkei
selbst die Regeln einhält sich selbst in
Europa zum Beispiel für Feiern
tatsächlich auch unterschrieben hat
deshalb wir sollten gemeinsam mit den
anderen europäischen Partnern sollten
wir gemeinsam eben sehr deutlich uns
Erwartungen sagen und das eben nicht als
deutsche Zeigefinger sondern eben unter
Verweis auf die gemeinsamen Regeln die
mir im Europa hat gemeinsam haben sagt
Michael Link der Chef der
internationalen Wahlbeobachter Mission
hier in der Türkei danke dass Sie heute
Abend bei uns waren ja danke schön
ja bei den Parlamentswahlen die es
gestern auch gab hat ein Bündnis rund um
Erdogans akpartie die absolute Mehrheit
geholt ein Bündnis dem extreme Rechte
angehören und islamistische Parteien mit
radikalen Forderungen mit risentiments
gegen Flüchtlinge und gegen Kurden es
gibt Menschen hier die leben seit
gestern noch mal mehr in Angst in diesem
85 Millionen Einwohner Land haben über
15 Millionen Menschen kurdische Wurzeln
die prokodische Oppositionspartei HDP
ist über ihr Ergebnis ernüchtert Kamera
sie werden verfolgt verhaftet Kurden in
der Türkei bei Razzien werden im Vorfeld
der Präsidentschaftswahlen dutzende
Funktionäre und Bürgermeister der
kurdischen Oppositionspartei HDP
festgenommen
wir sind Erdogan wirft den Kurden
Verbindungen zur verbotenen kurdischen
Arbeiterpartei PKK vor
ja den Kurden ging es eigentlich noch
nie so schlecht wie unter Erdogan die
Kurden mussten als Minderheit im Prinzip
am meisten unter dieser Diktatur von
Erdogan leiden und deswegen setzen sie
im Moment jetzt alles daran um auch
diesen Zustand der Unterdrückung und
Verfolgung zu beenden die Kurden sind
über vier Länder verteilt gelten als
weltweit größtes Volk ohne eigenen Staat
und 20% der Menschen in der Türkei haben
kurdische Wurzeln seit Jahren kämpft die
verbotene kurdische Arbeiterpartei PKK
einen blutigen Kampf wenn unabhängigen
kurdischen Staat bei den Wahlen galten
die Kurden als Königsmacher doch die von
ihnen unterstützte Opposition hat den
Sieg verpasst viele Kurden wie die
aktivistinische chillig sind enttäuscht
wir sind Anhänger der Demokratie und
wollten dass sie gewinnt aber die Wahlen
haben uns gezeigt dass der Nationalismus
in der Türkei stärker ist als die
Demokratie
die Kurden lange sucht Staatschef
Erdogan eine Ausdehnung mit ihnen doch
als sie 2015 erstmals ins Parlament
einziehen geht Erdogan auf
Konfrontationskurs prominente Vertreter
wie den früheren ko-vorsitzenden der
prokurdischen HDP selectin Demirtas
steckte ins Gefängnis auch Osman Kavala
ein Verfechter der Kurdenfrage sitzt den
Haft
die Kurdenpartei HDP droht sogar ein
Verbot
für die Kurden aber auch für die
Opposition geht es im Prinzip um Alles
oder nicht es steht viel auf dem Spiel
die
Opposition insbesondere auch die Kurden
wollen wieder zurück zu
parlamentarischen Demokratie Präsident
Erdogan möchte Festhalten an seinem
autokratischen Präsidialsystem und das
bedeutet aber für die Kurden weitere
Unterdrückung weitere Verfolgung und
Repression auch im autonomen
Kurdengebiet in Nord- und Ost Syrien in
der roger war hierfür Erdogan Krieg
gegen die Kurden kritiker sprechen von
ethnischer Säuberung
Erdogans Ziel mit allen Mitteln ein
großkurdistan verhindern
Stichwahlen am 28 Mai sie werden über
das Schicksal der Opposition und somit
auch über das weitere Schicksal der
Kurden entscheiden
ist bei uns er ist Präsident des Foren
policy Instituts hier in Ankara Herr
Professor schönen guten Abend schön dass
du da sind erklären Sie uns bitte ihr
Land da galoppiert hier die Inflation
die Wirtschaftslage ist wirklich
verheerend die Menschen man fragt sich
immer wie die Menschen über die Runden
kommt tatsächlich Freiheiten werden
immer stärker beschnitten und dann das
verheerende Erdbeben wie holt jemand mit
so einer Bilanz fast 50% der Stimmen das
interessante seit 21 Jahren ist daran
der Regierung und viele Leute haben sich
daran gewöhnt und wir haben eine
Generation die nie jemanden anderes
kennengelernt haben und es ist
interessant auch wie er überhaupt die
Massen an sich sieht hypnotisiert wenn
Sie wollen und die Leute wählen ihn aber
die Wahlen von gestern eigentlich für
die Nichte einen totalen Sieg nennen im
Gegenteil er hat ja wie kann unter 50%
mitbekommen deswegen es gibt kein
Gewinner zurzeit aber bei den
stichphasen werden wir mal sehen wie es
ist aber teilweise an wie gesagt ist
eine von den erfahrungensten Politiker
der der westlichen Welt seit 20 Jahren
ein wirklicher Politprofi sagen Sie
jetzt habe ich mich gefragt ich habe im
Erdbebengebiet mit vielen Menschen
geredet die wirklich alles verloren
hatten das ist wirklich schwierig zu
fassen gewesen ihre gesamte Familie hier
habe und gut und wenn man sie dann fragt
wie geht's jetzt weiter dann sagen sie
häufig jetzt kann uns nur noch einer
retten Rezept erdogan ist er mehr schon
als ein Politiker ist er so eine Art
Heilsbringer hier mittlerweile für
manche Menschen in der Türkei es gibt
solche Aussagen dass er eine halbe
Stunde es ist nicht der ist ein normale
Politiker der immer wieder die waren bis
jetzt gewonnen hat und was interessant
ist natürlich dass er
in der im Lande die Massen an sich
bringt weil er durch seine Rhetorik
durch seine durch seine Aufsehen durch
seine Art und Weise einfach die Massen
wirklich seit 21 Jahren an sich bringt
und deswegen ist jetzt für mich keine
Überraschung dass diese Leute im
Erdbebengebiet in gewählt haben aber
diese Psychologie sollten wir vielleicht
auch wissenschaftlich untersuchen wie
kommt es dann überhaupt dass er in eine
solche Lage in eingebracht wird also er
wie ein Prophet Auftritt für diejenigen
die in diesem Gebiet waren wir in dieser
Sendung schon häufiger gehört dass er
durchaus ganz gute Chancen hat
tatsächlich Präsident in diesem Land zu
bleiben bei der Stichwahl was wird dann
mit diesem Land passieren aber das ist
eine interessante Frage wir werden mal
sehen aber die Gesellschaft und sind
nicht statisch die Gesellschaft und
ändern sich und man darf auch nicht
vergessen dass er mit seiner Rhetorik
polarisieren Motorik in den nächsten
fünf Jahren an der Macht ist aber diese
Rhetorik wird der höchstwahrscheinlich
ändern müssen wenn er weiter gewählt ist
aber sofern kann ich sagen dass er diese
Rhetorik nicht nur im Inland aber auch
im Ausland ändert wird er die Rhetorik
eher runterfahren oder wird er hier noch
noch stärker setzen auf das was ihr in
den letzten Jahren gezeigt hat ich denke
er wird noch weiter er hat gesehen dass
diese
konfrontationale Politik im Internet
auch im Ausland ihm nicht viel geholfen
hat deswegen versucht er jetzt alles was
er nicht richtig gemacht hat zu
korrigieren in daraus und so wie in
Deinem Politik sagt professi ich danke
er hat sich das über uns waren danke
schön
so wir kommen gleich noch mal zurück
hier nach Ankara aber erst hat Gundula
jetzt in Mainz den Blick auf all das was
auch noch wichtig war heute
in Bremen hält sich spd-wahlsieger boven
Schulte nach der Bürgerschaftswahl die
Optionen offen möglich wären weiter eine
rot-grün-rote Koalition ebenso wie ein
Bündnis mit der CDU die SPD hat laut
amtlicher Hochrechnung 30,1% erzielt die
CDU
25%. die Grünen rutschen um 5 Punkte auf
12% ab Maike Schäfer Spitzenkandidatin
und bisherige umweltssenatorin kündigte
ihren Rückzug an die Linke kommt auf
11,1 die FDP auf
5,2%. da die AFD nicht zugelassen war
profitierte die rechte Regionalpartei
Bürger in Wut in Bremen erzielt sie 9,7
in Bremerhaven
22,7%. dort ist sie zweitstärkste Kraft
der frühere Bundeskanzler Gerhard
Schröder darf trotz seiner engen
Verbindungen zu Russland endgültig in
der SPD bleiben die
Bundesschiedskommission der Partei wie
es in letzter Instanz Einsprüche gegen
die jüngste Entscheidung in der Sache
zurück
der ukrainische Präsident selenski hat
sich mit mehreren europäischen
Verbündeten getroffen nach Zusagen für
Militärhilfen in Italien Deutschland und
Frankreich hat er weitere Unterstützung
von Großbritannien erhalten premier
sunek sagte hunderte zusätzliche
Flugabwehrraketen und Kampfdrohnen mit
einer Reichweite von mehr als 200
Kilometern zu unterdessen hat das
ukrainische Militär nach eigenen Angaben
Fortschritte bei den Kämpfen um bachmut
erzielt
Energiepolitik und Menschenrechte stehen
im Fokus des antrittsbesuchs von
Außenministerin baerbock in der
Golfregion auch über die Krisen im Sudan
und im Jemen sprach sie in jeder mit
Saudi-Arabiens Außenminister Prinz
Bienen verhahn das Königreich hat in
beiden Konflikten eine Schlüsselrolle
inne morgen wird der Bock ihm Emirat
Katar erwartet
dank sinkende Energiepreise und leicht
zurückgehender Inflation hat die
EU-Kommission ihre Konjunkturprognose
für die Eurozone etwas erhöht nur
deutschland hinkt hinterher und ist fast
Schlusslicht Valerie Halle wie belastbar
ist diese Prognose das muss man
natürlich sehen die Prognosen der
einzelnen Institutionen aber gehen schon
etwas auseinander was Deutschland
betrifft ist Brüssel ein wenig
pessimistischer als die Bundesregierung
ja vielleicht wichtigste Aussage Europa
aber auch Deutschland bleiben mit hoher
Wahrscheinlichkeit eine Rezession
erspart ausschlaggebend war tatsächlich
dass die Energiepreise gesunken sind was
die Produktionskosten der Unternehmen
senkte außerdem haben die Lieferengpässe
nachgelassen und der Arbeitsmarkt ist
stark für die EU-Wirtschaft rechnet
Brüssel dieses Jahr mit einem Plus von
einem Prozent für die deutsche
Wirtschaft hingegen nur ein Mini
Wachstum von
0,2%. die Energiekrise die deutsche
Industrie besonders hart getroffen weil
sie lange vom günstigen Gasthaus
Russland profitiert hat keine Entwarnung
gibt die EU-Kommission bei der Inflation
die bleibe in Europa mit fast sechs
Prozent hoch allerdings eine gute
Nachricht für Arbeitnehmer Brüssel
rechnet auch mit nachhaltigeren
Lohnerhöhungen vielen Dank Valerie nach
Frankfurt
das Bundeskartellamt hat Prüfverfahren
gegen mehrere Gasversorger eingeleitet
wegen des Verdachts ungerechtfertigt
hohe Endkundenpreise auch wird überprüft
ob diese Versorger nach den Preisbremse
Gesetzen möglicherweise überhöhte
Erstattungsanträge gestellt haben
und wir schauen noch auf ein
außergewöhnliches Experiment es geht um
den längsten Aufenthalt eines Menschen
unter Wasser ohne Druckausgleich in gut
9 Metern Tiefe hat ein Professor der
biomedizintechnik den bisherigen Rekord
von 73 Tagen in einer wohnkapsel
gebrochen insgesamt will Joseph die
Touri 100 Tage unter Wasser verbringen
um herauszufinden wie der menschliche
Körper langfristig auf erhöhten Druck in
der Umgebung reagiert
der Mann der die Türkei seit mehr als 20
Jahren regiert und es vielleicht auch
künftig tun wird hätte allen Grund sich
in Deutschland zu bedanken von den über
3 Millionen Wahlberechtigten außerhalb
der Türkei lebt fast die Hälfte bei uns
in Deutschland es sind Stimmen auf die
sich Receiver Erdogan blind verlassen
kann sein Stimmenanteil etwa in
Nordrhein-Westfalen war deutlich höher
als in der Türkei selbst und auch noch
mal höher als bei der letzten Wahl
Dominik Müller Russell berichtet
eine Machtdemonstration gestern am
späten Abend in Duisburg
erdogan-anhänger feiern ihren
Präsidenten mit großer Inbrunst und
immer wieder dem
türkisch-nationalistischen wolfsgruß
und auch heute in Köln bei Tageslicht
als klar ist dass es eine Stichwahl
geben wird lassen viele keinen Zweifel
daran wir hier das Sagen hat
seitdem ich klein bin bin ich für den
seit 20 25 Jahren mittlerweile er ist
der beste besser geht's nicht was sollen
die anderen machen es gibt doch keine
andere Option würde ich sagen die
Opposition ist das seit 20 Jahren die
gleiche und
der Graben ist tief auf der anderen
Seite verfolgt der türkische
journalistan dünder gestern Abend in
Berlin gemeinsam mit Freunden die alles
auf eine Stichwahl hinauslaufen wird und
während in Duisburg Autokorso starten
fragt er sich ob er jemals wieder in
seine Heimat zurückkehren kann
ich hatte erwartet dass diese Autokratie
nun beendet würde und wir wieder eine
parlamentarische Demokratie bekommen und
natürlich dass wir Erdogan loswerden
aber es scheint als wäre er immer noch
die macht unser Schicksal hängt nun von
zwei Prozent ab 49 % für dann was das
für uns aber bei 51%, dann können wir
zurück stell dir vor dein Leben hängt
von zwei Prozentpunkten ab
nun also Stichwahl zwei Drittel aller
Deutsch Türken die abgestimmt haben
haben Erdogan gewählt auch dank guter
Lobbyarbeit der UID die als
Interessenvertretung von Erdogans AKP im
Ausland gilt sie will mit ihren
Argumenten mit dafür sorgen dass alles
im Sinne Erdogans ausgeht
Herr Erdogan hat den Türken hier auch
Selbstbewusstsein gegeben das heißt die
Türkei ist wieder wer ist ein Global
Player geworden und vor allen Dingen
auch ein Land was auch mal
Ungerechtigkeiten anspricht und all das
sind Faktoren was dazu geführt hat dass
die in Deutschland lebende Türken hier
gesagt haben ja wohl das ist mein
Präsident nur knapp ein Drittel der
Stimmen aus Deutschland gingen an
Herausforderer nun vor der Stichwahl
gilt es zu Kämpfen machen sich die
chp-anhänger Mut die Wahl ist enorm
wichtig für die Türkei für die Menschen
die in der Türkei leben für uns alle
mit Kindern die Demokratie wieder zurück
die unabhängige Justiz Gerechtigkeit
Gleichheit und diese Spaltung des Volkes
wird mit ein Ende haben die
Wahlbeteiligung war hoch und wird es zur
Stichwahl wohl wieder sein vom 20 bis 24
Mai werden Türken in Deutschland wieder
wählen können
die Türkinnen und Türken nehmen ihre
Wahl sehr ernst ich habe hier Menschen
getroffen die durchs halbe Land oder um
die halbe Welt gereist sind um ihre
Stimme abgeben zu können ihnen allen ist
künftig ein tatsächlich fairer und
chancengleicher Wahlkampf zu wünschen
und noch etwas anderes neben den großen
politischen und wirtschaftlichen
Problemen die dieses Land herausfordern
haben wir hier überwältigende
Gastfreundschaft erlebt die bleibt
das heute journal Update mit Wolf
schmiese von hier gegen Mitternacht
Horst Checker aus Ankara und Ihnen allen
einen angenehmen Abend
[Musik]
guten Abend hoch Tina tief Benedikt und
tief chapeau ziehen alle weiter nach
Norden das hochuller zieht ein bisschen
weiter nach Osten so gibt es bei uns zum
Teil kräftigen Regen zum Teil aber auch
tiefere Temperaturen das merken wir
besonders nachts aber es fällt viel
Regen in den Alpen und südlich der Alpen
bis Mittwochabend können in Oberitalien
bis zu 180 Liter Regen pro Quadratmeter
fallen auf der Alpen Nordseite sind es
bis zu 80 Liter Regenbogen pro
Quadratmeter etwas Regen fällt heute
Nacht schon zwischen dem Emsland und dem
Oberrhein sonst lassen die Schauer
erstmal nach und zum Teil das ist im
Osten auch klar dann findet sich Nebel
an der Donau die Temperaturen sinken auf
10 bis 4 Grad und morgen bleibt es
frisch für Mitte Mai in der Westhälfte
da liegen die Höchsttemperatur nur bei
12 bis 16 Grad etwas milder wird es
Richtung Berlin an der Elbe oder auch an
der Donau Richtung München mit 17 bis 19
Grad das Regenband der Nacht zieht
morgen Vormittag weiter nach Südosten
sonst wird es ganz freundlich an der
Nordseeküste Entwick ELN sich einige
Schauer und nachmittags setzt dann der
Energie die Dauerregen am alten Rand ein
und mit dem haben wir es dann auch noch
am Mittwoch zu tun der Feiertag Christi
Himmelfahrt am Donnerstag wird dann
schon sehr freundlich bei etwas
steigenden Temperaturen von 11 bis 20
Grad und wie sie hier am Temperatur und
wettertrend für Berlin sehen können
peilen wir dann früh sommerliche Werte
von 25 Grad oder mehr an guten Abend